my name is Kelly and I'm a software
engineer and the analytics engineering
team at C and today I wanna talk to you
a little bit about the Giulia language I
know we're at high data but Padilla has
had a julia related talk for a few times
julia is a num focus sponsored project
since 2012 and we are very good friends
and siblings with python and so today i
would talk to you a little bit about
what's great and special about Julia and
how easy it is to pick up Julia from a
Python background python was actually my
first programming language and then I
picked up Julia in college because I
went to MIT Julia was develop at MIT and
we used Julia to teach our dinner
algebra class I really liked how simple
and fast julia was so I also joined a
Julia lab MIT and did my senior thesis
there and since then I've been involved
in the Julia community in a few
different ways and I continue to
appreciate Julia and the people who make
our community so special and thank you
for coming to my talk and for your
interest in Julia let's dive right in
and so a brief agenda for today is an
introduction to Julia what I love about
it and how you can start coding in Julia
today this is a quote from the internet
famous worry dream about Julia that I
really like note that it was returned in
2015 so I I agree with everything said
in this quote by I wanna point out that
since then Julia has become a lot more
stable and mature and it has definitely
branched out from just a scientific work
branch it's a very general language
people use it for pretty much everything
and especially with our much anticipated
1.0 release last year
yeah the language has really involved a
lot the first of why Julia as we can see
here this is a periodic table of
programming languages color-coded by
their features we already have a sea of
languages offering
different features so why did the Julia
creators and also the open source
community think that it will be
worthwhile to create a new language
given all those existing languages and
the reason why is because we have a two
language problem in way in which
traditionally a language is either
performant like Fortran C and the
assembly language or productive like
Python Ruby MATLAB and so it seems like
there is a trade-off between performance
and productivity and sometimes people
have to translate between low and high
level languages however this is also not
the entire story we also need to
consider generality how regular rules of
a language without exceptions are easy
to learn use describe and implement and
so if we if you need all those three
features a classical workaround is to
use two languages people will start with
a language that they can prototype in
such as python and matlab and when they
want to launch things in scale and the
performance they use a lower level
language such as C and that gives us the
two language problems
so on the Giulia project started in 2009
its goal was to combine performance
productivity and generality and now it's
very exciting and so a tagline for
Giulia that we like to say is true that
looks like Python feels like Lisp and
rinse like C and I will go through the
three parts first performance here I
have a chart comparing the runtimes were
a few commonly used functions like loops
and recursions in different languages
compared to C and we can see that
Julia's performance is very comparable
to C and that's why we say it runs like
C and Julia code can actually be faster
than typical optimized C or Fortran code
sometimes because it uses techniques
as metaprogramming and coach and
generation that are hard in a low-level
language and Julia's multiple
dispatchers natural fit for defining
number and array like data types and
we'll talk about that in a little bit in
second productivity for a sum function
both Julia and C takes about ten
millisecond and Python takes about five
hundred millisecond so you can see here
that the implementation between Python
Julia are not that different so you're
actually using very similar syntax but
getting more than a magnitude of
performance improvement and actually I
personal I personally know a number of
grad students who started using julia
for the first time because they had
working python code but they wanted some
they wanted more performance so they
translated a python code for julia and
discovered how easy that was and started
using julia and finally i want to talk
about during reality and this is what we
meant when we say julia feels like a
list because this has a large language
center including many built-in data
types functions and macros as we
mentioned before julia uses
metaprogramming such as multiple
dispatch for example i can write a bunch
of collide functions like this and when
i run what I call collide XY at runtime
Julia will dispatch the correct
implementation because in Julia the
virtual table is essentially stored on
each function instead of on each class
when in call functioning Julia it will
look up in a table at runtime which
concrete function it should be based on
it should call based on the type of the
arguments and in fact multiple dispatch
was a central design concept in truth in
Julia gulia standard library uses more
than double the amount of overloading
dining other languages and more than ten
times in the case of binary operators
and another really cool thing about
Julia is much of julia code was written
is written entirely in Julia's
see in this jubilant repo and this is
really cool because it allows users of
julia to also contribute to the
development of the language and actually
a lot of people start contributing to
julia because they were using julia in
their work or research and they wanted
to make some modifications to make
things work better for their purposes
and now i want to talk about one
application of julia the celeste project
and it remains number one on the
berkeley national labs top ten big data
problem so it all started in 1998 in
1998 the Apache point observatory in
Mexico began imaging every visible
object from over 35% of the sky and the
project was known as the Sloan Digital
Sky Survey
it included around 500 million stars and
galaxies light from the most distant of
those galaxies has been traveling for
billions of years but for 16 years the
process of cataloging the stars and
galaxies was painstaking and people
didn't really want to touch the data set
because it was so big and this is how
big the data that was but in 2015 2014 a
team of astronauts for this computer
computer engineers and statisticians
from the Berkeley National Lab UC
Berkeley MIT national energy research
scientific computing Center and Intel
began working on this last project they
spent three years developing and testing
a new parallel computing method that was
used to process this huge data set and
this project was written entirely in
Julia it was able to produce the most
accurate catalog of 188 million
astronomical objects in just fourteen
point six minutes achieved the peak
performance of 1.5 for petaflop using
1.3 million night learning notes on the
Cori supercomputer at the nurse making
Julia part of the petaflop Club
and this last project showed us how
julia facilitated cross department
collaboration because the scientists
physicists engineers they all began
working on the same code base from day
one and there was no translation from
between high and low level languages and
of course the project showed us the
superb parallel computing capabilities
of Julia which I also appreciate very
much in the limited amount of research
and work I've done using julia so now we
have a general idea of julia i want to
talk about what i put i really like
about it um as mentioned beginning I
started using julia in college in first
in-class and done in research and then
I've also used Julia I might work I'd
see a little bit first this is a slide
from a numerical method class that I
took in college my project partner and I
built a paralyzed SVD algorithm that is
the singular value decomposition
algorithm it was for pure fun we wanted
to see if we could be Julia Julia's
building SVD algorithm which already was
very optimized and we wanted to see if
returning julia wikipedia and we ran our
algorithm on google flume java which is
a data per data parallel pipeline in
chop with c and here i screenshotted our
a slide in our presentation we came up
with a pretty insane runtime and also we
used comics and for our presentation but
reflecting on that project i want to
point out a few things about julia first
Julia takes math very seriously excels
and numerical computing and the syntax
is great for math yes Julia also
supports numerical datatypes and
together with a performance advantage it
was kind it was like a match made in
heaven I remember the days when I used
MATLAB or Mathematica and even for class
projects my laptop would like make
really loud noises and second Judea
provides parallelism right out of the
box like even for something like that we
like that we did a bunch of optimization
parallelism you can write parallel steps
for even very small functions julia has
several built-in primitives for parallel
computing at every level factorization
multi-threading this distributed
computing Julia's native multi-threading
allows us to take advantage of the power
of a multi-core laptop and his remote
call and most primitive allow
distribution for work across many
processing a cluster oh that is built
for parallelism and julia uses
addressing time compiler which means
code is compiled during execution
instead of prior to execution and this
has benefits in terms both in terms of
performance and security and it allows
us to remember complicated models and
also julia can be easily integrated with
Fortran C Python and others for that
project we integrated with C there's a
built-in class C call where you can call
C function directly Julia I personally
also use pi PI called JL package a lot
and there's also this really popular
packaging are called ARP Julia and and
in addition Julia can be embedded in
other programs there is embedding API
and then when I worked in the Julia lab
I actually did computational physiology
research and I really appreciate that we
have Jupiter notebook notebook support
and I like to think that Jupiter is
Julia Plus Python and there are also a
lot of good plotting and visualization
packages
there and I like that there are a lot of
options to choose from for example there
are some flaws that I made with a gap
fly dodge al package and julia has a
great package ecosystem I think we're
over 2000 packages at this point and the
very friendly supporting developer
community personally I'm a fan of biro
Julia github org it contains a list of
packages ideal for bioinformatics and
computational biology research and of
course again julia has great cost
support to other languages as well and
actually in the project I'm going to
talk about next I used our julia a lot
and julia has been increasingly popular
among data scientists because of the
many managers we just talked about in
terms of numerical scientific computing
performance and productivity at sea i
worked on the project to implement
sequential testing on our AP plus AP
testing platform to limit peaking
behavior from our stakeholders who were
so eager to conclude their experiments
as soon as they saw positive results
because again i'd see it's an e-commerce
company and for a lot of new feature
development with an AP test and then we
make project decision based on the
result of those experiments and I work
on the AP testing platform and we and
for a long time
for a long time we use p-value and power
to indicate statistical significance and
so our stake holders which is look at
the result page every single day and
once they see that the P has reached a
certain level they're like oh yeah we
can conclude your experiment but we all
know that's not the case and that's the
classic peeking problem and so so we
ended up implementing something like
dislike p-value threat hope threshold
curve but while we did the work we did a
lot of simulation and research into
different methods simulation of
simulation of fake experiment data and
talking about the other science I'd like
to talk about the New York Federal
Reserve Bank they've been using Julia
for almost five years they replaced a
lot of their old models in MATLAB with
Julia and they use Julia to estimate
models which is ten times faster than
their old MATLAB models to compare
self-test which is 11 times faster and
to reduce number of lines in half which
of course save time reduce error and
increased readability and Julia has been
increasingly popular especially in
FinTech and insurance insurance company
yeah and for for the New York Federal
Reserve Bank and actually me as well we
found that Julia handles more kinds of
models more easily and I specifically
want to mention Julia's type system it's
dynamic but also has some advantages of
static typing for example you could
indicate you could indicate that certain
values of a specific type and you expect
return of a specific type for example
you can specify types of variables like
unsigned 32-bit integer but you can also
create general cases like writing a
function that accepts integer without
specifying the land or signing up the
integer and you can also do it without
typing entirely if you need it the
default behavior in julia when types are
omitted is to allow values to be of any
kind so we can use many useful julia
functions without ever explicitly using
types one additional expressiveness is
needed it's also really easy to
introduce expert
the type annotations adding annotations
allows us to take advantage of Julia's
multiple dispatch which I had just
mentioned and in no particular order I
won't just mention some other things
that I love about Julia first Julia
allows you to write pretty much anything
even a web application and you can
deploy it on a web server
Julia packages also naturally work very
well together this is thanks to the
language function composition which
makes it easy to pass two or more
functions as arguments julia has a
dedicated function composition operator
for achieving this this seems trivial
but I love Julia's indexing system it's
one indexed and Julia's slice indexing
includes the last element and julia 1.1
introduced a debugger suite which
executes code in the local read eval
print loop and allows you to stop stuff
through the results inspect variables
and add breakpoints in code and this is
pretty big for a new language and at
last i like that julia allows us to
assign mo jeesus variable names and so
with that i want to show you some real
code in julia and to see how it's very
easy to start coding in julia
yeah and it's it's a notebook written by
andreas who who's from MIT and with
others from me and Jane Herman first a
right I want to talk a little bit about
erasing functions before we before we
dive into like matrices arrays it's very
simple syntax it's just like pretty much
any language here with the final
Fibonacci and also you don't have to
always have the same type in an array
for example here you can have integer
and string in the array and as I
mentioned Julius 1 index so to get the
two strings you would call 5 to 6 and 2
to add and delete an element from an
array it's also pretty standard it's
just a push and pop function call and
functions there are actually three ways
to code to define functions in Julia
first is the ones that I have shown in
my slide you would use a function and
end keywords like you can say function
say hi and print a line function define
a very simple math formula so when I say
say hi Kelly you print out and f-18
gives me 18 square and you up you could
also declare functions you want in a
single line just using an equal sign
like this and then it's the same and
also you can declare anonymous functions
like this so when you output when you
rent that line and didn't say function
say hi 3 as a function that was the 23rd
anonymous function that I had so that's
number 23
and like this so those are the three
ways to define functions and now let's
define Iran so Julia's a lot of the
matrices been a auto-related syntax in
julia is very similar to matlab here we
define random matrix and we can define a
vector of ones using the phone call and
we notice that this a matrix has a type
of integer 64 2 but X has type array
well 64 1 so Julia defines aliases
lecture as array type 1 and matrix as
array type 2 and array operations yeah
so I want to talk about a broadcast and
map operations they are pretty similar
similar to our a MATLAB for example map
just in taxes like this you are just
square you're just getting squared
getting the square of one two three four
five and
yeah and this and the broadcast function
here we are we are adding up C and we
are adding one to each to each role of
in D to teach low in ii ii ii ii ii
gentleman in second row three so that's
the broadcast function and basic
operations are the same as in other
languages for example multiplication at
the star yet and but what's different is
julius call into program known as open
blas so that so that way it's an
optimized multi-threading operation for
example when we do the c dot star d
which is an element-wise multiplication
it would be faster transposition it's
also the same syntax as matlab and we
can get the transpose with transpose
transpose multiplication we can omit the
star and just do a transpose a solving
linear systems the proc this route that
this is solved by the backslash function
which is also pretty standard but note
that a box RP will give us the least
square solution if we have an
overdetermined linear system like this
give us the square solution and it will
give us the minimum normally square
solution if we have a rank deficient the
squares problem like this
it's ranked efficient and Julia also
gives at the minimum norm solution while
you have a short matrix like this and
even though a lot of the linear algebra
available in Julia is by default there's
also a standard library in algebra and
it brings a lot more relevant names and
functions and as with using any packages
with we can incorporate those features
into a session using a using linear
algebra call for example this dot call
it just kills the dot product and this
cross cog after the cross product and
finally I want to give a spotlight to
use function here you can see that in
the first case making B didn't allocate
an array
I just an object with a pointer this is
actually what I only say up it's all in
the notes but oh the array itself is the
memory layout and for julia erase this
is actually a c pointer to a continuous
one dimensional solid memory the array
type in julia is the view to the actual
array of view is a type which points to
an array and has a compatibility layer
that changes how things like the
indexing works and i think there's a
pretty similar concept in the umpire as
well and it's also called view but this
array is actually a 16 number long
sequence in memory and a is a view to
that to that array which make us make
the index like it was a two-dimensional
therefore the
a one-two one-two-three one-two-three it
isn't a few to the same memory and we
can check this by call but we can say B
is a 1 3 1 3 cell b11 to be 100 and that
doesn't change a because because this
first element is still not 100 but
instead if we want a few we can use the
view function so we can copy as view a 1
3 1 3 and that way when we change the
element at 1 1 in B that also changes a
yeah and they're there cases where you
might want to use a view but we're not
gonna go into that and with that that's
all in the show just a little bit
favoring to Julia
oh sorry this okay
so finally I want to mention again just
how great the julia community is it's
full of very smart and kind people and
everyone is very willing to help whether
you're a beginner or experienced julia
user we would love to have you and i
said we have a ton of packages the
package ecosystem is constantly
improving and um I'm actually involved
in organizing Julia Khan it's the annual
conference with Julia and attendees come
from a diverse academic and professional
backgrounds and different julia
proficiency level it's a lot of fun and
learning from and interacting with our
global community this year I was
involved in the diversity and inclusion
effort and next year I she will be the
inaugural social chair so I think will
be the most fun Julia :
and last um a lot of wonderful people
have written some wonderful resources
about Julia this intro to Julia link on
the jewel an official website has a ton
of really useful links and tutorials to
get you started and I also want to
mention two resources that I like in
particular one is a deep introduction to
Julia for data science and scientific
computing it's written by Chris caucus
he is one of the most prolific Julia
contributors and another one is think
Julia how to think like a computer
scientist the name might be familiar to
you because it's written by the authors
of think Python and I also introduced I
also included the centralized resources
place for Julia packages we have I have
this we have 2000 and 367 packages at
this point a link to other research that
uses Julia and also a link to how you
can start contributing to Julia it's
very easy and I think start contributing
to Julia is a great way
to also get started in Julia and and
yeah thank you thank you so much